سنوات من النظر الى هواتفنا الذكيه او الى
شاشات الكمبيوتر ستغير اشكالنا على النحو
الغريب وفقا لنموذج مندي ساعات النظر
الطويله الى هواتف ناس ستؤدي الى ظهور
انحناءات في الظهر وليس ذلك فحسب بل ايضا
الى اعناق اكثر سماكه عندما تعمل على جهاز
كمبيوتر او تنظر الى هاتفك يجب ان تنقبض
عضلات الجزء الخلفي من الرقبه لرفع الراس
الاظافر ستتحول لمخالب فالطريقه التي نحمل
بها هواتفنا يمكن ان تسبب اجهادا في بعض
نقاط الاتصال ما يتسبب في تكوين مخلب لليد
الاضرعي ستكون بوضعيه زاويه ال 90 درجه هي
ناتجه عن الوضع المعتاد للذراع عند حمل
الجهاز كذلك جمجمه اكثر سمكا ودماغ اصغر
وجفن اخر فقد يطور البشر جفنا ثانيا اكبر
لمنع التعرض للضوء المفرط ايضا سيكون هناك
جلد شاحب لقضاء سنوات محاصرين تحت وهج
الضوء الاصطناعي